vous savez ce que je viens de réaliser
je vais faire comme si on se faisait un
super joli périple en italie et je vais
faire comme si tu étais toujours mon
cher mari aimant du thème et toi prise
tu vas faire le bagage contre aval on
est encore en lune de miel du coup primo
c'est kelly sûr secundo et je voudrais
que ce soit clair j'ai promis à ma
thérapeute de ne plus être gardes du
corps je ne protège plus personne sa
mission et l'huile de la
décision ne l'as pas la route les bébés
doivent être conçus dans dans un
environnement stimulant en tant que
femme je dois être excité par l'idée de
faire du shopping et d'excellents dîner
alors là on est officiellement en lune
de miel elle vient de parler de dîner
entre temps arrêté il faut qu'elle reste
concentrée sur la route or ces bruits ok
je vais gérer vous inquiétez pas je
produis m que vous avez à faire pour
être appuyé un peu sur le frein
salut futur michael c'est le michael
d'aujourd'hui je pense que tu serais
fier d'apprendre que je suis
officiellement en congé sabbatique je
sais pas pourquoi j'ai pas fait ça plus
tôt en fait pour la première fois depuis
que kinkaid a tué kurzawa je commence à
imaginer une vie sans gardes du corps
c'est vraiment un nouveau départ
déjà vu ce qu'on se connaît tous les
deux je m'appelle sonia qin kai la mafia
kidnappé mon mari faut qu'on aille les
somme non non non il n'est pas question
que je m'appliquais j'ai des consignes
thérapeutiques tres tres j'arrive en
face que darius non plus mes rêves on
aura les bouches tonquedec malpoli
et tout au monde qui brille brille ce
serait bien que tu te réveilles
on est planqué en italie parce que des
gens veulent notre peau
coutu et poser tes mains sur mes deux
seins j'ai cru entendre le petit garçon
qui est en toi qui hurlaient c'est pas
du tout ce que j'ai hurlé je crois pas
non
alors faisons ce qu'on sait faire le
mieux
allons tout faire exploser amenez moi
c'est de là dans ma chambre des tortures
vous auriez des chambres des tortures
séparer
n'oubliez pas ces mots va prendre fin
[Musique]
ah
c'est la merde
où est votre chemise
bonjour
[Musique]